do you feel sometimes that you would
have an easier time being like say an
individ individual without having to
like worry about management and things
like that oh that's right well you know
the way that i kind of view it is yeah
there are restrictions and for the most
part i get why they're in place um right
here right now with me as i am um i'm
happy to kind of like
work around things for example there are
games that i can't always stream and
that's i can't do it at all actually and
that's fine a lot of them are ones that
i like a lot um but at the end of the
day
like i said been trying to be more
positive recently so the way that i
think about it is you know what out of
this list i will choose the ones that i
like and i will have fun with them and
um i think that's the best way to go
about it because you know life is uh
life is long
for the most part for the most part
and um
yeah
because of me uh it's not as long as it
could be but um
but however however
um you do a lot of things uh in in your
life and your existence you know and um
what one life ends one begins etc you
know that's how it was for me a long
time ago um so you never know what the
future will hold but right now with me
as i am uh just the mori in front of you
um
i can find workarounds and ways to still
have fun uh with the restrictions that
are in place and i think that that's
that's kind of the attitude to have if
you're gonna go into this and um
and uh and join a big company like like
whole life yeah you know you just gotta
you gotta kind of work with it get over
it you know is it something that you
were expecting the restrictions or was
it kind of a shock
you know i think in the beginning i
thought that it would be a bit different
however i don't think like i mentioned
before none of us knew how big this was
going to be yeah yeah you know and when
that happens things kind of things kind
of change a bit
right when there's more money involved
more people get involved
yeah when stuff blows up everyone wants
to take credit for it yeah
we live in a
society we
we're trying to keep this politics free
thank you very much society yes
stay positive you know um what are some
of like the top ideas that you would
want to do if you like you had no
restrictions at all oh man it's mostly
games to be honest that i think about
collabs that i'd want to do with people
that just can't realistically happen you
know and um
and uh it's like there's there's not
just like protest from from my side
either from management but also from
from people who watch me and like i pay
attention to that kind of stuff i don't
let it completely influence me but like
i i do look at it um and try to you know
factor in as much as i can so this is
why i have like no energy because
there's so much going on in my brain
analyzing so you pay attention to what
games the chat wants you to play i do
but that's because like i genuinely want
like everyone to have a good time and if
i see the same thing happen over and
over again you know it gets it gets in
my mind but again it goes back to the
point where i said you can't every
single nice thing that said to you
that's a critique is not necessarily
going to help you will be helpful to you
so i just try to keep that in mind um
and stay open-minded the whole time but
it's mostly just games and collabs that
i wish i could do that i kind of
realistically can't but it doesn't mean
that they'll never ever happen ever in
the history of ever it's just it's just
not like this yeah and i think that's
fine personally thank you for letting
cali come back on trash taste yeah thank
you very much thank you appreciate it
and um i certainly am happy to be a
guest here yeah yeah thank you speaking
of future though like what's what's in
the future of cali
recently um you know there's a lot
there's a lot of ideas that i have
especially in terms of uh original song
a month that's still a thing that's
happening um i've got a big big collab
song coming out um with a fellow member
of en i think i've talked about this i
don't know how much of this will be
teased by the time that this comes out
but i hope you guys are looking forward
to it it is huge and we're working with
a huge producer like like the likes of
which i never thought i'd be able to
work with somebody
could you imagine the guy who wrote the
pokemon rap
and kelly
i'm excited
i'm very excited
i hope that you guys will enjoy it we've
been working really hard on it and um
yeah in general um i'm just trying to
prepare for another big release someday
and um
you know also in my in my crystal ball
we've got a possibility of um i'd really
like to do a world tour someday
you know that'll be that would be hype
yeah that would be hot i mean definitely
definitely at some point while i'm doing
this um
hopefully we will get a world tour
fingers crossed the world needs to open
up first before we have a world tour
well i say the world the world can't
heal until cali goes to every country
that's not possible the grim reaper has
to heal you yeah the healing has not
been done yet
it hasn't happened
to me aside from that though in the more
immediate future we have anime nyc
happening on november 20th november 20th
that's right we have a booth there
chad's like yeah yeah
that's it um we have a booth happening
um
it's nice to see that's a white board
being used for something other than
nyc we have a booth a holo booth but at
that same at that same place we have a
collab popping off i'm sure you guys
have seen by now uh with omocat
um who is he's designing clothes for all
of us in holo en uh myth right now and
so that is extremely exciting um because
i've been a big fan of cat for years and
years and years it's like a dream collab
oh geez yeah oh yeah yeah really amazing
amazing work and um also the creator of
omori i played that game on stream uh it
was a long stream
okay my favorite endurance streams of
all time so yeah i'm just really glad
that you know we got to we got to work
with all of them and uh yeah it's just
really cool i'm excited for you guys to
see the clothes they're awesome please
buy them please wear them uh and go
check out the booth yeah sounds like
you've got a lot of exciting things
coming up yeah there's a lot going on
stacked schedule
yeah right
even now there's still a lot of fun
stuff going on which is a relief that
after a year it's not like things are
slowing down or anything now we've still
got a lot going on and you guys haven't
seen everything that that myth or even
ian has cooked up just yet so stay tuned
i have a feeling you'll you'll continue
to be very busy yeah yeah it just seems
like it's speeding up yeah i was just
like maybe you'll find some free time
coming up oh the world's opening back oh
[ __ ] me man
it's like where do i find time well
sleep's only like six hours can i work
while i sleep
i'm gonna figure that
that's why you were talking in your
sleep before you were
planning your next moves
why am i screaming in my sleep
what's going on
yeah but i guess before we end things
off i do have a question for you yeah
you did give me a [ __ ] about pizza crust
last time you did so i gotta ask
um
boneless chicken or in bone chicken
boneless
i know what i'm talking about i'm done
guys thank you for coming to this
episode of trash this is just the most
awesome i i would shake your hand but
we're on a different virtual plane
exactly i am in another dimension so
it's kind of rough but
congratulations virtual high five for
that one
is now the fourth member of trash taste
cali is now the third member of the
church
i'm going to ask this every time a guest
comes on i'm going to find one [ __ ]
person who is on my side tell me why
boneless is better than that yeah why
why do you like the wait oh boneless
white's better than bone because the
bone's annoying exactly i mean i don't
want to eat around them it's worth the
taste okay it's worth the taste and
you're starting to see all the little
veins and like dark spots pop out it
just it's nasty i don't want to eat the
chicken anymore i think you should stop
asking that question unless you want to
get owned every episode i'm no i'm i'm
going to find a fellow brother or sister
so someone is going to come here and
back me up okay
one day one day you know who you are
you're out there right now i'm waiting i
am waiting for that time pov you're
gonna go to him
he needs this oh my god
i'm no longer a youtuber fan now
wait a minute
friendship would be cheaper
bone chicken is my best friend
if i got like 50 wet wipes on hand yeah
we can talk about doing it you know but
i don't want to
let's not start this